It's been more than a decade since hot-shot
rookie racer Lightning McQueen burst on to
the big screen in the first Cars movie.
Now, he's back in Cars 3 with a cast of new
characters, as well as old favourites, to
get his life back on track.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers, it's Jan here
and in this video I'm going to uncover some
amazing secrets and facts about the making
of Pixar's latest animated movie.
I'm also running my special Cars 3 giveaway
on this video as well.
For a chance to be one of two lucky people
who'll win this very cool The Art of Cars
3 hardback book featuring Pixar's fabulous
concept art, storyboards, and insights into
the movie, all you need to do is subscribe
and leave a comment about the film, and also
answer the question I'll be asking later in
the video.
Many years of work go into each of Pixar's
animated features, and, naturally, over the
course of those years, screenplays and character
designs go through numerous changes.
In fact, during the production of Cars 3,
artists created over 80,000 storyboards for
the film, however, only around 10,000 of those
made it into the final movie.
But thankfully, sometimes the animators on
a new movie can make use of the good work
done by their colleagues on a previous Pixar
film.
For example, when you look at the sky in Cars
3, 85% of those clouds you see actually came
from the cloud library for The Good Dinosaur.
Although, sadly, screen legend Paul Newman
died back in 2008, his Cars character Doc
Hudson still plays a crucial part in the new
movie.
And Doc is voiced once again by Newman himself
thanks to many hours of conversations between
the renowned actor and Cars director John
Lasseter that were caught on tape during voice
recording sessions for the first movie.
A lot of what Newman and Lasseter talked about
between takes was racing-related, so when
the filmmakers trawled through those recordings
looking for material that would work for Cars
3, they had a veritable treasure-trove of
dialogue to choose from.
When the animators were working out how Lightning
McQueen's face should move, they looked to
Owen Wilson, the voice actor behind the car,
for inspiration.
Which means that the way Lightning moves his
mouth in the movie is based on the shape of
Owen Wilson's mouth when he talks, including
the way the actor curls and purses his lips.
The movie's design team wanted the look of
next-gen racer Jackson Storm to be in complete
contrast to the look of Lightning McQueen.
So, they went for a sharp, angular design
for Jackson which stands out compared to Lightning's
more rounded, flowing look.
In fact, Jackson Storm is actually how the
Pixar team think a stock-car racer will look
20 years from now.
As for the "S" symbol on Jackson's side, that's
based on the international hurricane symbol
which has been tweaked, stretched and colour
matched to give him a sleek and bold look,
and to contrast with the lightning bolt on
number 95.
For the appearance of school bus Miss Fritter,
the filmmakers took a subtle style cue from
Orange Is The New Black star Lea DeLaria who
voices the demolition derby champ.
Yes, just look at Miss Fritter's face and
you'll notice that the animators increased
the thick rubber trim around her windshield
in a hat tip to DeLaria's trademark thick-rimmed
glasses.
On top of that, Miss Fritter's smokestacks
are another cool easter egg as their design
is based on the horns of the classic Disney
character Maleficent, who featured in the
1959 animation Sleeping Beauty as well as
the 2014 live-action movie starring Angelina
Jolie.
By the way, for more awesome easter eggs in
Cars 3, tap the top right of the screen to
check out my video on that.
When it came to bringing to life the movie's
crazy demolition derby, with all its mud and
dust flying everywhere, the filmmakers discovered
how difficult it was to make computer-animated
mud that was the right consistency so it looked
realistic but didn't totally cover up the
characters.
To give you an idea of just how big a task
this was for the artists and technicians working
on Cars 3, there are actually 616 shots in
the movie that feature mud, splatters, sand,
dust, and dirt.
One of the things the filmmakers did to ensure
they got the right design and feel for the
scene overall was to visit a night race on
a dirt track.
After that, it was a matter of trial and error
to get the mud looking less like either cake
icing or liquid chocolate, which is how it
looked in early tests, and more like the combination
of chunky oatmeal and soup that director Brian
Fee wanted.
When Cars 3 production designer Jay Shuster
joined Pixar back in the early 2000s, one
of the first things he had to do was design
a pay phone that could function for a large
mechanical object that had no hands like a
car.
Shuster's pay phone design ended up being
cut from the first Cars movie, however, in
a little nod to the production designer, the
pay phone has been re-introduced in Cars 3,
so look out for it during the scene at Flo's
V8 Café.
A chance encounter with a Vintage Car rally
during a meeting the Cars 3 team had away
from their Pixar offices gave the filmmakers
the idea to pay tribute to the history of
racing and early NASCAR racers in their movie.
Among the characters in the film based on
real-life NASCAR legends is Louise "Barnstormer"
Nash who is named after the 'first lady of
racing', Louise Smith, who won 38 races in
the 1940s and 50s, and whose Nash Ambassador
car lends its number, 94, to her Cars 3 counterpart.
NASCAR legend Wendell Scott, who was the first
African-American to win in the Grand National
Series, also inspired the Cars 3 team to create
a new character called River Scott, who races
under number 34, just like Wendell Scott did.
Also, Doc Hudson's old coach and friend, Smokey,
who Lightning McQueen turns to for help in
his own career, is based on real-life racing
legend, the innovative mechanic Henry "Smokey"
Yunick, who, just like his name-sake in the
movie, ran an automobile repair shop that
he dubbed 'the Best Damn Garage in Town'.
Oh, and to emphasise the bond in the movie
between Smokey and Doc Hudson, who was a Hudson
Hornet, the animators based Smokey's design
on a Hudson pick-up truck.
Now, what was your favourite moment in Cars
3?
And who's your favourite character in the
Cars movies?
For a chance to win this awesome The Art of
Cars 3 hardback book, be sure to subscribe,
and leave a comment about the movie, and also
answer the following question:
Which Disney character is Miss Fritter's design
a reference to?
Make sure you turn on your notifications to
get all my new Cars 3 and Pixar videos and
I'll be announcing the winners for the giveaway
on an upcoming video.
Congratulations to these 2 winners of my recent
Alien: Covenant giveaway!
If you're one of them, send me a message on
YouTube or via my email which you can find
on my About page so I can get your details
to send you the prize.
If you enjoyed this, I really appreciate you
hitting that thumbs-up button and check out
some more of my Pixar and movie secrets videos
right here.
Thanks for watching and see ya next time!
Yippee-ki-yay movie lovers!